well on sunday as we said earlier the
mayor of new york the mayor of new york
bill de blasio
said he's shutting down schools and
non-essential businesses whatever that
is a man who's never
worked in a business in his life in
several zip codes in the city including
in brooklyn and queens
what did these zip codes do wrong well
more than three percent of coronavirus
tests came back positive for a week
no word on how many people died that's
not even part of it
they just had positive tests what's
interesting is that
just the other day practically bill de
blasio said he wasn't
against mass gatherings as long as he
agreed with the politics people were
expressing watch
things that here in the city can mean
not just thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people it's
just not time for that now
what about protests if people want to
march down fifth avenue are they gonna
be allowed to do so
look walt this is always an area of real
sensitivity we understand at this moment
in history people are
talking about the need for historic
changes this is a historic moment of
change we have to respect that
oh so when you go to church try to have
a jewish wedding in brooklyn
you're a threat to public health but if
you're looting macy's it's a historic
moment for change
as soon as you say something like that
out loud the rest of us no longer have
to listen to
anything you say because you're a fraud
you're a liar
you're totally irrational and you no
longer have legitimacy to lead
period today the governor of new york
andrew cuomo decided to approve the
closure of many non-essential businesses
that's not because he's opposed to
lockdowns he thinks the real problem is
religious services watch if the
religious leaders
do not agree to abide by these rules
then we will close the religious
institutions
period really because in the country we
lived in in january we had a first
amendment that said
government will not get in the way of
your exercise of your religion
people would have laughed at that we
will close the religious institutions
period
who do you think you are god you're not
you're some stupid governor of a
declining state
many of the services being shut down by
the war in orthodox jewish communities
they haven't been playing along to their
great credit
putting aside whether any of that is
legal what's the science behind it the
purported science behind it
protests fine religious services not